قالت هيئه عائلات الاسرى الاسرائيليين
بغزه ان نشر تسريبات من لقائهم مع نتنياهو
عندما هاجم قطر يعد جريمه ويعرض حياه
الاسرى للخطر واشارت الهيئه الى ان المصدر
الوحيد للتسجيل والتسريب هو مكتب نتنياهو
والمقربون منه ووصفت هيئه عائلات الاسرى
الاسرائيليين بغزه سماح الرقابه العسكريه
بنشر التسريبات بانه خطير جدا مضيفه انه
يجب على اعضاء مجلس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
المصغر منع تكرار
ذلك وكانت صحيفه ها ارتس الاسرائيليه قد
قالت ان الرقيب العسكري وافق على نشر
تسجيلات لرئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو ضد
قطر بعد التشاور مع مكتبه فيما اكد بيان
لديوان رئيس الوزراء انه لم يصدق على نشر
التسجيلات وليس هو الطرف الذي قام
بالتسجيل خلال الجلسه وقد نشرت القناه
الثانيه ع الاسرائيليه في وقت سابق تسجيلا
لنتنياهو خلال اجتماع مع ممثلين لعائلات
الاسرى المحتجزين في قطاع غزه ينتقد فيه
دوله قطر ويقول انها لا تختلف عن الصليب
الاحمر والامم المتحده واضاف نتنياهو في
التسجيل انه احتج لدى الامريكيين على
تجديد عقد القاعده العسكريه مع
[موسيقى]
قطر
ي
[موسيقى]
م
خ